Jordan Peterson and Dave Rubin are
banned from Twitter what's going on well
nothing new there really it's just
they're more of the same I think uh no
it I was talking to with my co-host for
trigonometry Francis about this in the
studio today and I was saying can you
imagine that they've we've got to a
point where to to state a historical
fact about someone's biography is now a
crime essentially it's at least in
Twitter's eyes you're gonna get banned
from a social media platform for stating
historical fact about an individual
which is what both uh Jordan and Dave
have done here uh and I think it speaks
to the situation that we're in which is
uh the ideology behind all of this it's
just become so perverse and has been
allowed to run a mock so far that we
live in this clown world uh and unless
Elon Musk is able to take over and
change some of this I don't I don't
really see how how we're gonna get out
of it do you think Twitter is that
important is a is it still the Town
Square for public discourse I do think
that and of course you could say Well
only whatever percent of the public even
in Western countries are on Twitter and
it's true but then that is where the
discourse happens because most people
aren't on Twitter because they don't
want to be part of the discourse they
actually have you know jobs and kids and
and things they actually want to achieve
in their life instead of getting angry
with each other so I do think it's the
Public Square and I do think it's really
important and I also think it's
essential that correct principles are
modeled in the space because the sort of
high culture discourse then leaks out
into the rest of society and you see it
you know in my former career of Comedy
people now happily getting up in the
middle of a gig and shouting stuff at
comedians not in the old way where it
used to be a sort of heckling and
battling and that used to be fun I
really used to enjoy that but it's like
no they'll go to complain to the people
who run the club afterwards and demand
that this comedian is never allowed to
perform so it I think the sort of
behavior that's modeled in this type of
Public Square is actually really
important and of course the rules they
impose then get filtered down to other
areas as well and other people feel well
you know if Twitter's going to shut
these people down well we're allowed to
shut them down in real life with it you
know not invite them to speak or ban
them from speaking and so on so I do
think it's really really important
actually yeah so the culture of
censorship on Twitter has more
Downstream impacts perhaps one of the
interesting things now is that tweets
become news right previously people were
tweeting about things that happened in
the news but now the news can be derived
from what people tweeted so there's this
very sort of cyclical game so just for
the people that haven't seen it the
actual tweet that Dave got suspended for
there's a difference between a
suspension and a ban uh the ban is if
you would I think being completely
removed from Twitter a suspension you
have to do this kind of struggle session
where you admit that the Tweet was wrong
and delete the tweet and acknowledge the
fact that the Tweet broke terms of
service but Dave's tweet was
um the insanity continues at Twitter
Jordan Peterson has been suspended for
this tweet about Ellen Page he just told
me he will never delete the Tweet paging
at Elon Musk and the warning from
Twitter says he may not promote violence
against threatening Iran for the people
on the basis of race ethnicity national
origin sexual orientation gender gender
identity religious affiliation age
disability or serious disease and that
was uh enough to get Dave a strike
yeah and there's a couple of points I
pick up there the first one is you talk
about the struggle session and it's a
really good reference because you're
talking about of course Soviet Union and
uh China uh and uh this is exactly you
know one of the things I talk about in
the book I know we'll get on to it later
is how Soviet some of some of the things
that we are now doing are because this
is exactly what used to happen in the
Soviet Union if you wanted to if you
made some kind of faux pas and you were
not politically correct enough again as
you know I talk about the origins of
political correctness in the book then
what you would have to do is you'd have
to publicly come out and say I comrade
you know and you'd have to give this
whole speech about how you you'd messed
up and this is what they make you do
they make you sort of admit that you've
done something wrong instead of just
you know even just punishing you for
breaking their rules even if as in this
case I I don't think there's any
credible evidence that Dave Rubin was
inciting violence or hatred towards
somebody by using a name that person
used to use until about three seconds
ago
so dead naming is it seems like the
thing that Dave's been popped for there
yeah well clearly and I it's funny to me
as well because I don't know if you saw
this obviously you're in the US now but
in the UK we have these sort of supposed
conservative uh parliamentarians uh the
banned protesting too loud in public and
one of the ministers tweeted about it
saying finally we've put an end to the
violent speech of blah blah blah and
this was somebody was just using a
megaphone in public right so even the
conservatives are buying into all this
[ __ ] because once you accept that
words of violence this is an inevitable
consequence if you buy into this
completely nonsensical Dogma the words
are actual violence then of course you
know we we do have laws and rules that
are aim to prevent and regulate uh
violence and so you're gonna end up
regulating people's speech what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace